hello freak bitches what do you do with
your time these days like what's a
typical day for Hicks and Gracie right
now I back to teach in close place
because I wanted to to have him Morris
Dees stress with the how the Academy
goes so I pick two times a week to teach
they're giving self-defense classes at
this point before that I was doing
seminars once a month at the most once
twice every couple of months to to make
my living and also because I feel like
the best things in life money cannot buy
and I feel like the quality of my my
meals the way I eat the way my
relationship my sleep those are very
very valuable assets you know plus the
time I have to do things I love to do
that's kind of when this is fuel like
when I feel like I'm everything so I
feel like I'm happy enough to be my best
at service because I always try to be at
service helping somebody with jiu-jitsu
with knowledge with nutrition with
breathing you know it's not about the
prices about the service you know and
then I put my head in the end up and
said yeah I'm a I'm a have a nice day I
make a good speech with Joe Hogan I'd
have a garage talk with and Bravo was
great day so somehow in a purpose for
the Federation so I always try to be
positive but I have no schedule fixed
like I have to wake up vote no because
at this point I create a lifestyle which
make me feel good to engage in different
elements like this Federation now and
having classes on crowns and be here to
be full of energy you know because
sometimes you don't notice but based on
your your your commitments your
obligation you becoming more like a
Robert and you lose the perspective of
what you need to be at your best and if
you lose that perspective even though
you still do in your routine
sometimes you just - you're just 80 70
60 % of what you should be so you're not
going to be the best husband you're not
going to be the best father the best
employer the best employee you just you
know it's just so at this point I feel
like I have to be at my best physically
do my if I feel like I have to stretch I
going to stretch breathe joke have fun
this and party whatever you know and
then when I feel like man I'm so happy I
could not eat so and then I can go and
do my service you know and no because
the window of life is smaller and now
for me it becomes I don't have too much
time so I don't waste time to do what
people expect from me I try to do things
I really relevant to my soul like this
Federation now I when I dream I don't
dream small I dream like I make like a
very space for a hue day the biggest
dream I can dream and I see that moment
you know that level of need for the
community and the level of position I
have to be the reference for that shift
in the direction of our culture in our
knowledge I feel like I could not be
more motivated more happy to engage in
this so and that's always life is about
is just do your best and and and be
excited to be motivated to to to the
next day there's such a refreshing
attitude your your attitude your
philosophy on life because I think it's
very easy and I've been I've trapped
myself in it sometimes where you
concentrate too much I'm making money
concentrate too much on being ambitious
and you forget the quality of life yes
your focus is almost entirely on your
quality of life yes you know because
like I said man how much cost your
motivation how much cost your friends
how much cost your health how much cost
your intelligence those things is
priceless
I mean if you take those of your life
you take a motivation of your life can
be Bugis can be the biggest so if you if
you ask me if I want to have do gates
life I don't know I don't know him so
it's not a base on his bank account is
based on how happy is how
or here's how you know how how how
motivated I used to wake up and do his
thing
you don't look too horny I don't think
so so that's is that's a very essential
thing which sometimes sleep to people's
fingers and and the priorities in the
daily you know in the payments and so I
put you in a role where I feel like if
you tell me in the past
what's the courage what's the opposite
of courage I want to say cowardness
because either you tough enough to to
challenge and to fight or to or in then
you coward and you chicken out so that's
in the past was like the opposite of of
courage it's very hard to measure this
in those days and I believe the opposite
of courage today is conformity you know
as people get conformed oh I don't like
my wife the way I used to like but I'm
never going to divorce because I'm
afraid to lose my house or the situation
is so established so I'm going to keep
so I don't like this job but I'm going
to keep here because better than his so
in in other hands if you if you get
caught on that kind of compromise to to
maintain because you you afraid to risk
let's keep you like one step behind from
you follow your heart follow the
ambition you 18 years old you don't
think twice like I say yeah let's go to
Australia you think okay let's go poom
but when you feel to say Australia what
I'm going to do there maybe I'm gonna so
it's different you know me and that's
kinda hater oh my god
yeah so that's kind of pretty much where
keep you from be at your best because if
you willing to sacrifice if you willing
to to broke new new challenges if you
willing to you in a stage of liveness
and an excitement and unpredictability
who make you feel like you in heaven you
know every time I was engaging in a
compromise or a fight what's something I
thank you like I have my routines prior
fight one of them is at the day of my
fight I wake up and I think
you got to be alive and I acknowledge
how perfect will be that day if I die
today say fuck my was a baby a perfect
day if I die because I have you know I
accomplished my think I'm in my mission
I represented my family so I don't go
that you tap I go that you die like I
have to kill me it's not I'm never going
to tap so but that's not a sport like
orientation this is a philosophical
owner representation you know it's not
something I teach my snow it should not
that no it's not like that it's about
how I feel how I feed my kids how I
follow my tradition so in engagement I'm
not going to be the one who gonna quit
did I have to kill me
my brother he can throw the towel but
for me is unacceptable you know I did
give up from my life so based on that
kind of spirit or guidance my life is
very intense my life is very I mean
directed to accomplish give up is not an
option you know I can I can direct my my
my focus I can give up from something to
go somewhere else
but I never will give up from something
because I feel like I cannot reach there
I may say okay that's not for me I go
somewhere else but if I still focus I
will take those Falls I will take those
obstacles as a motivation to just set up
a new strategy to try again you know I'm
very competitive in a sense
I like the perfection of things so this
is like a situation where put you in a
situation where you have no either you
go forward or you don't but don't stay
in the middle don't try just waiting for
people who are waiting for more those
are kind of things gonna stack you back
in life and and just make you feel like
passing through life as you enough you
haven't you know you in relevant you
know this is very quick